thank you to ancestry for supporting pbs
i desired liberty for liberty i gasped
for liberty i uttered a prayer it seemed
scattered on the wind then faintly
blowing
i abandoned it and framed a humbler
supplication
for change stimulus me during the
quarantine
romping about the more with your
star-crushed jerk boyfriend when all the
signs
be they supernatural or mundane have
gathered to tell you that this
romance is a kind of messy cyst
plus spooky manners and constantly
roaring winds we must be
in the bronte zone
[Music]
jane eyre by charlotte bronte was there
for the weird girls
the quiet ones who watched and listened
the ones who pined away for someone to
accept them in all of their weird
dark doc martin glory but in the nearly
175 years since its publication
the collective definition of what it
means to be a woman on the outside of
society
has changed and expanded dramatically as
it should
and yet here we are still dissecting
charlotte bronte's words and gravitating
towards jane
as a protagonist for those of you who
have never read jane eyre or enjoyed one
of the
8 000 films television stage or media
adaptations not to mention the countless
literary retellings i mean
so many let's get into it written and
published in 1847 under the pen name
kerbel call back uh previous video i was
in it uh
check it out jane eyre concerns the life
story of a titular heroine from
childhood
up until her mid-20s you know the only
years that really matter for a woman
jane an orphan child
is left to the care of her wealthy but
highly
abusive awning cousins who verbally
emotionally and physically torment her
to the point where any self-defense is
labeled as her
acting out she is sent away to an oster
boarding school for girls
not even in the fun way where the
headmaster is equally abusive and cruel
watching as her fellow classmates are
all punished near starved and in the
case of her best friend there
left to die from infectious disease
several years later after reaching
adulthood
jane leaps at the opportunity to see
more of the world
when she takes a governance position at
the totally creepy mansion
thornfield hall which is owned by the
curmudgeonly
edward rochester from there on the story
splits into
two paths i'm totally in love with this
jerkface boss who
lies to me and plays mind games with me
because i'm
the help and completely below his
station romance
and the wait why do i hear creepy
laughing
and footsteps every single night and wow
who is setting beds on fire
gothic fiction the two genres women are
absolutely the best
at who can lie spoiler alert it's mr
rochester's mentally ill wife bertha
hi bertha say hi bertha also
spoiler alert jane doesn't find out
about bertha
until seconds before she almost marries
mr rochester
real keeper of a guy but we can fix him
will jane and mr rochester's dark torrid
romance finally be
realized will jane find the self-love
and confidence to stand up for herself
well wait he
locked a woman in an attic
like this is a romantic lead
while immensely popular and beloved
today having sold
hundreds of thousands of copies in the
last 50 years alone
and translated into dozens of languages
including
esperanto okay flex
it is perhaps for the best that air was
published under a pseudonym
as critics were eager to rip it into
shreds
for its comparatively dark moody heroine
content
said contemporary critic and historian
elizabeth lady eastlake of the book
we do not hesitate to say that the tone
of mind and thought
which has overthrown authority and
violated every code human and divine
abroad
and fostered chardism and rebellion at
home is the same which has also written
jane eyre wow tell us what you really
think of it
but where jane eyre becomes important is
its place in the tradition of the
building's roman
or simply a novel about a person's
formative years
while jane eyre is not the first novel
told from a lower middle class woman's
point of view
it is the first noticeable buildings
roman that has one as its main subject
it is also told in the first person
putting the reader directly into her
thoughts and
forming world view across the years the
idea of the self
is a priority in the text since jane
isn't gutted by
heroics but what she thinks is good for
her
and what will keep her alive towards the
end of the book jane is presented with
the opportunity to be a good
middle-class english woman when the
stuffy
self-righteous minister saint john
proposes to her and promises to take her
with him to india as a missionary
serious colonization vibes there but at
the last minute jane takes a look at him
and says
nah i'm gonna go back to the crazy
flandering lying bag of hammers that is
mr rochester
i mean he's bioronic don't you think
again call back i was in that video have
you watched it
you should says professor of literature
sharon losi
in this respect jane eyre is atypical in
its appropriation of the male
pattern of development for its
protagonists
jane's story begins as theirs do in her
childhood when she is 10.
female protagonists of the courtship
novels mentioned above
rarely ever leave home or do so only
within the prescribed orbits of young
women preparing to marry
jane eyre on the other hand moves
through the world like a boy
but if we're gonna talk about jane eyre
rochester and what this book has meant
for feminist literature
then we need to talk about bertha
rochester's wife that he kept
in the attic for over a decade because
women be crazy bertha is the troll name
of the term mad woman in the attic
authors in the 19th century were
confined
to make women either angels or monsters
and
in that binary we have jane and bertha
in their foundational criticism the mad
woman in the attic
authors sandra gilbert and susan goobar
defined this binary
between the two women as the main
confrontation of the novel
calling it a secret dialogue of self and
soul
on whose outcome we shall see the novels
plot
rochester's fate and jane's coming of
age all depend
bertha in other words is jane's truest
and darkest double
the angry aspect of the orphaned child
the ferocious secret self
jane has been trying to repress ever
since her days at gate's head
bertha mason in jane eyre is the evil
ghost-like woman
who haunts thornfield hall only seen
through the perspective of rochester who
views her as a toxic beauty
i thought i loved her her relatives
encouraged me
competitors piqued me she allured me
a marriage was achieved almost before i
knew where i was
oh i have no respect for myself when i
think of that act
i never loved i never esteemed
i did not even know her alexa
played the world's smallest violin
rochester sees himself as a victim of
the mason family
who didn't tell him about bertha's
mental state and when she started to
deteriorate
rochester locked her in the house for 10
years
which i'm sure 100 had no side effects
on her mental health
whatsoever and we're supposed to root
for this guy
bertha stands in the way of jane and
rochester because rochester
never divorced her and so he would be a
bigamist if he married jane which
is bad while bertha's race is and can be
assumed to be white
there's an implication of otherness and
how he compares
jane to bertha due to birth of being
crayol
a white person raised in the west indies
she's got a little too much
seasoning for rochester's english
palette if you get by drift when
relating why he was picked by the masons
rochester says
her family wished to secure me because i
was of a good race
and so did she this could have many
implications including that bertha's
family may have somewhere down the line
mixed with the black population and were
no longer perceived as fully white
as susan l meyer professor of english at
wellesley college explains
an interpretation of the significance of
the british empire in jane eyre
must begin by making sense of birth and
mason rochester
the mad drunken west indian wife who
rochester keeps locked
up on the third floor of his ancestral
mansion
bertha is killed in the burning of
thornfield hall which she does
that also leaves rochester blind she
jumps to her death freeing herself from
imprisonment
which you know honestly good for her in
the end how sympathetic birthday was
supposed to be in the 19th century is a
little hard to
understand since she is such a haunting
figure in the novel
but in a post-colonial sense bertha is
utterly tragic
especially because rochester basically
says it wasn't me in terms of taking any
accountability for the situation
that caused them to be married like grow
up dude
you're an adult hence why we need to go
to the greatest way
readers can examine text fan fiction
with white sargasso c
written by white dominica author jane
reese white sarcaso c is a response to
jane eyre which tells
bertha's story bertha becomes antoinette
causeway
an heiress in jamaica and her story is
broken into three parts that discuss her
childhood
marriage to a nameless english man and
then her fate
in england as a captive in part one we
see antoinette's childhood
on a sugar plantation that has gone
belly up since slavery was abolished
yay suck it antoinette's mother attempts
to marry
another different wealthy englishman in
order to fix their money problems
hearing this through the grapevine the
freed slaves end up burning down the
plantation
which results in antoinette's brother
passing away and
exacerbating all the mental health
issues that already exist within the
family
one of the most iconic scenes of the
book is when antoinette goes to a black
jamaican girl named tia
to try to escape the reality of her
burning home during this small revolt
as i ran i thought i will live with tia
and i will be like her
when i was close i saw the jagged stone
in her hand but i did not see her throw
it
i did not feel it either only something
wet
running down my face i looked at her and
i saw her face crumple up as she began
to cry
we stared at each other blood on my face
tears on her
it was as if i saw myself like in a
looking glass
the character of tia is a foil for
bertha as a black girl of the same age
during the fire bertha antoinette goes
to tia and tia throws a rock at her
because despite antoinette thinking they
are the same
tia knows that she's the daughter of
freed slaves just in the same way the
english jane is a perfect example of
white superiority
over birth and her tainted implied
otherness
in part two rochester complains a lot
about being in the caribbean i hated the
mountains and the hills
the rivers and the rain i hated the
sunsets
of whatever color i hated its beauty
and its magic and the secret i would
never know
i hated its indifference and the cruelty
which was part of its loveliness above
all
i hated her for she belonged to the
magic and the loveliness
she had left me thirsty and all my life
would be thirst
and longing for what i had lost before i
found it
can someone get this man a lacroix it's
too hot it's got too many bugs
man i miss england and my under-seasoned
food
also i don't care or respect my wife's
mental illness so i'm gonna mess around
rub it in her face because she may be
crazy but i'm a man so
does it show that i'm not a fan of
rochester is that
is my bias showing what we see in
rochester
or this nameless man in this passage is
a man who feels unable to deal with
things he cannot control
and what he cannot control he loathes a
sentiment that does not seem so far
off from the man we meet in jane eyre
finally
part three antoinette's transformation
into bertha is complete
she has lost all sense of time as would
you if you were stuck in an attic for 10
years by your husband
there is no looking glass here and i
don't know what i'm like now
i remember watching myself brush my hair
and how my eyes looked back at me
the girl i saw was myself
yet not quite myself long ago when i was
a child and very lonely i tried to kiss
her
but the glass was between us hard
cold and misted over with my breath
now they have taken everything away what
am i doing in this place
and who am i literary theorist gayatri
chakravorty spivic explains
in the figure of antoinette who
rochester violently renames bertha
we suggest that so intimate a thing as
personal and human identity
might be determined by the politics of
imperialism
antoinette as a white creole child
growing up at the time of emancipation
in jamaica
is caught between the english
imperialist and the black native
in this fictive england she must play
out her role
act out of the transformation of herself
into that fictive
other set fire to the house and kill
herself so that jane eyre
can become the feminist individualist
heroine
of british fiction white sargasso c is
exhibit a
about how fanfiction and meditextual
examinations
can have real literary value when
copyright doesn't get in the way
it doesn't make jane eyre a weaker book
but highlights things that bronte
would not have been aware of bronte
talks about the realities of poor
working women
and does great work of giving sad
awkward brunettes
a true heroine but then you get bertha
a mentally ill woman who has been put
into a horrific situation
by her husband and the book goes jane
what am i responsible for actually
getting to know the woman i'm going to
marry
this is the 19th century she's lucky i'm
rich and white
that's why she even gets to live in an
attic of a mansion
she could just be living in the attic of
a townhouse
that would be tragic and perhaps one of
the most famous lines from the novel
jane thinking mr rochester is going to
marry a woman of
society cries out to her star-crossed
lover
do you think because i'm poor obscure
plain and little
i am soulless and heartless you are
wrong
i have as much soul as you and full as
much heart
it is my spirit that addresses your
spirit just as if both had passed
through the grave
and we stood at god's feet equal
as we are jane are the novels plead to
the humanity of women
of the lower station is both its
greatest staying power and one of its
most blaring weaknesses
and how it manages to advocate for
acceptance
while still creating an other in birther
who has not extended the same sort of
compassion in many ways bertha is a foil
to helen burns
jane's childhood friend who dies young
and is a perfect christian
bertha is all the women that were seen
as impure impure in their race impure in
their mental health
and dangerous because of both it is
racist and ableist victorian bs
and it has made bertha a legend and her
burning rochester's house is one of
literature's best
good for her moments and really all this
is over a man who literally dresses in
racist drag
so he can manipulate two women in hopes
of making
jane jealous justice for bertha
and honestly good for jane franklin's
waiting until she secured her own bag
to get her byronic husband because sadly
viewer
she married him thank you to ancestry
for supporting pbs
was that your great grandmother keeping
the family together
was that your great grandfather paving
the way for change did they brave mother
nature
and walk away stronger they face the
unknown
with resolve and triumph there is
strength in every family story
ancestry can help you learn about yours
visit ancestry.com for more information